خلال 4 أيام أه وقفة أه في كل
يوم سيكون هناك التزام على كل
جانب التزام على الإسرائيليين
والتزام على حماس التأكد من أنهم
سوف يقومون بهذا
الالتزام في كل يوم لذلك في كل يوم نهدف إلى
عدد من الإصدارات أه
لأن العدد كبير لذلك
حاولنا أن نجعل أه الطرفين
يتفقان على الإصدارات بشكل منهجي بمعنى آخر
سيكونون
جدول منظم يسمح بالإصدارات في كل
يوم وكل طرف مألوف تماما  الآن
مع
التزاماتهم تم إطلاق سراح 10 رهائن في اليوم
الأول على سبيل المثال ما لا يقل
عن 10 سيتم إطلاق سراحهم لذلك
تركز هذه الاتفاقية بشكل خاص على
النساء والأطفال المدنيين أه في كل
جانب في كلا الجانبين ونأمل أنه
خلال 4 أيام  سنتمكن من أه
استكمال إطلاق أه أه النساء
والأطفال في كلا الجانبين إلى
الجانب الآمن
بعيداً عن هذه الحرب بحلول الساعات الأولى من
الاتفاقيات سيتم إخطارنا بالقائمة
الرسمية أه الأشخاص في
كل يوم و بواسطة  بوجود تلك القائمة سوف
نتأكد من أننا نبلغ إما أه
حجم الأطراف نفسها
أو حتى أه الدول التي لديها
رهائن أه في قطاع غزة
حاليا حماس قالت ليس لديها
كل الرهائن وهي  تحتاج إلى وقت
للتجول لجمع معلومات حول
الرهائن الذين لا تحتجزهم ومعرفة مكان وجودهم. وقد
وصف الكثيرون ذلك بأنه
مجرد نقطة للحديث، حيلة ساخرة لكسب
الوقت، فالالتزام تجاه حماس في
اليوم الأول واضح جدًا أنهم بحاجة إليه.
لتزويدنا بتلك القائمة أه لقد تم
منحهم تلك الفترة من الهدوء وليس
فترة الهدوء فقط بل
منع أي اشتباكات عسكرية برية
غزو جوي مراقبة
ستوفر لهم المجال لتزويدنا
بذلك الالتزام الذي وصفته  في
لغة هذه الصفقة،
وصفتها بأنها هدنة في
قطاع غزة، وأعتقد أن اللغة مثيرة
للاهتمام حقًا، أما استخدام
مصطلح الهدنة، فهذا ليس وقفًا
لإطلاق النار بأي حال من الأحوال، وحقيقة أن هذا يحدث في
قطاع غزة  من الواضح أن الركيزة الأساسية لذلك
هي إطلاق سراح الرهائن.
ما يحدث فيما يتعلق بـ Aran Aid الإنسانية، ما
هو الالتزام على كلا
الجانبين فيما يتعلق بـ Opti in Aid،
بالتأكيد، لذا فإن هذا الاتفاق يحتوي على
عنصرين رئيسيين، الأول يتعلق
لإطلاق سراح الرهائن
والثاني يتعلق بتقديم ليس
فقط الكمية ولكن أيضًا
المساعدات الإنسانية ذات الجودة أه والمساعدة حسب
الحاجة أحد العناصر الأكثر إثارة للاهتمام
في تلك المساعدات الإنسانية
هو الوقود وإذا كان الوقود
قضية قابلة للنقاش  في الأوقات الأولى من
هذا الصراع، نجحنا الآن في
تأمين الوقود الذي يتم توفيره
للبنية التحتية الحيوية مثل المستشفيات
وغيرها، وكان الإسرائيليون
محددين للغاية حيث قالوا إن هذه
فترة هدنة قبل أن تبدأ الأعمال العدائية، وسوف
تستمر، وعلى وجه التحديد مرة واحدة  هذا
التوقف المؤقت هو أن الحرب سوف
تستأنف، وهو أمر مفيد في المفاوضات، وهو
هذا النوع من اللغة أه عملنا لم
ينته بعد، وما زلنا سنواصل التحدث
أكثر مع الأطراف لخفض التصعيد
للحصول على فترة أطول لوقف إطلاق
النار  الإسرائيليون لا يتحدثون عن
وقف إطلاق النار في هذه المرحلة، لقد
استبعدوا بشكل قاطع وقف إطلاق النار
حتى يتم إطلاق سراح جميع الرهائن، وفي
الوقت الحالي لا تتوسط في أي محادثات
بشأن الجنود أو الرجال الذين تحتجزهم
حماس، حسنًا، استمع حتى لو كان
بحر النار مؤقتًا.  لم يتم
أخذها في الاعتبار في وقت مبكر من قبل
الإسرائيليين، لذلك لا نزال نأمل في
ذلك وجهودنا لن
تتوقف عند هذا المستوى أه عملنا لم
ينته بعد، سنواصل العمل
مع الجانبين على أمل أن نتمكن من ذلك
تأمين هذا الهدف الأكبر إذا كانت
هناك عائلات من الرهائن تشاهد هذه
المقابلة اليوم، عائلات الرهائن من
الشباب في سن الخدمة، ما هي
رسالتك حول احتمال
إطلاق سراح هؤلاء الإسرائيليين في
أي وقت قريب، لذلك نحن نفعل
كل شيء  أنه يمكننا أه بمجرد أن
يرغب الطرفان في الاستمرار أه أه طلب
مساعدة أه قطر في الوساطة
سنرد بشكل إيجابي على ذلك
الطلب حتى نعلم أن مهمتنا
لم تنتهي وعملنا مستمر
من أجل الخير  وكما قلت،
أملنا حقًا هو أن نرى فترة
يمكننا فيها وضع حد لهذه الحرب والسماح
للناس بالمغادرة وأه تقليل هذه
المعاناة الإنسانية بالنسبة
للناس في
غزة، كان من المثير للاهتمام أه التحدث إلى
كبير المفاوضين و  لأنه وصف أيضًا
مدى صعوبة هذه المحادثات
وستظل كذلك عندما تتعامل
مع طرفين لا
يثقان مطلقًا أه في بعضهما البعض على الإطلاق ج
بالطبع المفاوض الرئيسي في هذا الشأن
إلى جانب أه مصر والولايات المتحدة الذين
كانوا  متورط جدًا وقد أخبرني أه
مصدر دبلوماسي قريب جدًا من
المحادثات وكان ذلك عندما وصل
رئيس المخابرات الإسرائيلية ديفيد بارا الموجود في
أم كاتا وفقًا لمصادر دبلوماسية
اليوم وبيل بيرنز أم رئيس وكالة المخابرات المركزية الأمريكية
يتعلق الأمر بأن هذا
كان نوعًا ما، كما تعلمون أن الزخم
لهذه المحادثات قد اكتسب بالفعل ولكن لا يبدو أنه
لا يوجد شيء مثالي ولكن ما لديهم على
الأقل من حيث المبدأ هو فرصة
هنا ولهذه العائلات على الأقل من
النساء والأطفال الذين ينتمون إلى
حماس  الأيدي في الوقت الحاضر هناك بعض
الأمل كما قلت لا نعرف من سيتم
إطلاق سراحه في اليوم الأول غدًا بعد الساعة 10:00
صباحًا هذا ليس واضحًا في
الوقت الحالي قال إن تلك القوائم على الرغم من
أنها جزء من الالتزام كل يوم أه
تحتاج حماس والإسرائيليون إلى وضع
قائمة على الطاولة بحيث يكون الجميع
واضحين من هو الشخص الذي سيتم إطلاق سراحه في
ذلك اليوم ويمكن بالطبع تمديد فترة الهدنة هذه
إذا سارت هذه الأمور كما هو
مخطط لها لكل 10 رهائن من حماس يتم إطلاق سراحهم
على سبيل المثال.  هناك فرصة أو
عرض لهدنة أخرى مدتها أيام كاملة